looking to get high on a new water
sport well you literally can riding a
flying water bike it attaches with a
long hose to the back of a jet ski
elevating you up to almost 40 ft above
the water where you can perform aerial
flips and Spins the jet skis water
thrust feeds three jet nozzles on the
flying water bike one propels the bike
upward the other two feed jet control
nozzles that maneuver the
bike the the bike's frame is made out of
aluminum parts because it has to be
lightweight as well as relatively
corrosion resistant especially if it's
going to be used in
saltwater this curv tube will become the
lifting
jet to build each jet control nozzle a
worker places a housing on an alignment
fixture then hammers an end cap into
position holding the housing steady with
a clamp the worker welds on the end cap
this housing will cover the the bushing
at the heart of the jet control
nozzle he inserts an elbow into the
opening in the end cap and welds the
parts
together after welding a jet nozzle cone
to the other end of the elbow he welds a
handlebar to the
housing these five welded parts make up
the body of the first jet control
nozzle to prep for painting the
manufacturers rough up all the aluminum
parts by tumbling them with abrasive
Stones this component splits the portion
of the water thrust that bypasses the
lifting jet sending it in opposite
directions to the jet control
nozzles the lifting jet tube now has a
nozzle cone welded to one end a coupling
for attaching the fire hose to the other
and an oval hole in the curve which
aligns with the angled end of a straight
tube in the middle called the
backbone
[Music]
after positioning parallel support bars
between the lifting jet and the splitter
the welder fuses all the parts
together then he flips the assembly jig
and welds on the seat
[Music]
support the seat support attaches where
the lifting Jet and backbone
meet after masking the ends of the
splitter a worker sprays the completed
frame jet control nozzles and other
aluminum parts with powder coat this
helps protect against
corrosion the parts go into an oven for
up to a half hour to bake the powder
coat to a shiny
finish then workers install an aluminum
cam lock to securely fasten the fire
hose to the
coupling another worker attaches the
remaining components to the frame first
he screws in the pair of foot plates on
which the Rider stands then he bolts the
bottom half of each plate to the
parallel support bars and the top half
to just ahead of the cam
[Music]
lock he mounts a padded knee rest to the
support bars it can be easily
repositioned to accommodate the rider's
height on each unpainted end of the
splitter he installs an internal support
Ray then a Precision Fit nylon bushing
and an external support ring which he
screws to the
[Music]
splitter the worker slides the jet
control nozzle housing over the bushing
and screws it to the internal support
ring the two control nozzles maneuver
the water bike to ascend you pull back
gradually on both of them simultaneously
to descend you push forward on both to
spin you move one forward and one back
and to do a back flip You Yank both
control nozzles all the way
back he assembles the water bike's body
it's made of molded polyethylene with a
waterproof urethane pad to cushion the
front of the rider's body the seat is
made of the same padded
material both pad and seat attach with
plastic
Clips the hollow body is completely
watertight which is why the bike
floats the final step is to mate the
body to the
frame the completed water bicycle weighs
lb once connected to a jet ski with the
fire
hose this water bike flies at a speed of
up to 20
mph by maneuvering the jet nozzles it
does back flips multiple spins and even
Dives 20 ft underwater
a throttle position sensor reports the
position of the throttle plate to the
engine computer so that it can decide
how much fuel to inject into the engine
and many other things without this
critical sensor the ratio of the air
fuel mix would be compromised and the
engine would likely
stall an internal combustion engines the
throttle position sensor is on constant
alert sensing the ne Neary power demands
to ensure a smooth ride making these
sensors starts with printed circuit
boards these boards will ultimately
process physical data and convert this
into information the engine computer
will
understand a robot transfers the boards
to a conveyor which takes them to a
solder screen printer the printer
squeegees solder through a stencil to
deposit it in specific locations on the
boards the squeegee and stencil then
retract and the conveyor shoves the
boards forward to the next
[Music]
operation here a robot retrieves
electronic components from tape on a
reel and deposits them on the soldered
spots on the
boards it collects multiple parts from
The Reel at one time and installs them
on the boards faster than you can blink
an
eye moving forward the printed circuit
boards arrive at a camera
station the camera clicks away and sends
pictures of the boards to a
computer the computer analyzes the
placement of each
component with the computer's okay the
boards head into an oven with different
heating
zones the oven melts the solder and then
cools it down to fuse the components to
the
boards
the oven then ejects the sensor
boards next a technician serves them up
to automated test
probes the probes energize the
components on the boards and in the
process collect
information they send the data to a
computer which analyzes the function of
the components on the board and to make
sure they're fully
[Music]
operational then the boards move to a
pneumatic punch it separates the 18
sensor circuit boards by cutting the
tabs that hold them
together a worker assembles a metal
spring to a plastic magnet
holder he places a highear washer over
the neck of the magnet
holder then he inserts the magnet holder
assembly into the throttle sensor
housing and places the unit in a
tray after glue has been injected in the
holders a robot moves
in it scans the holders and confirms
that there's glue in each
cavity it then inserts magnets in the
[Music]
holders a worker installs a torsion
spring in the housing it will hold the
magnet holder tight to the throttle
body he now inserts the printed circuit
boards into the sensor
housings
terminals in the housings made to slots
in the
[Music]
boards he solders the terminals to the
boards to establish the
[Music]
connections all the parts are now in
place for throttle position
[Music]
sensing a worker places covers over the
sensor board
compartments an ultrasonic weld then
melts the plastic at the
interfaces once it hardens the weld
bonds the cover to the sensor
body a robot pipes silicone adhesive on
the welded seam to create a double layer
of
protection the sensor is ride on a
conveyor that goes through an oven this
cures both the silicone on the welded
seam and the glue inside to secure the
magnet to the
holder out of the oven the sensors
travel through a cooling
station probes then power the devices
and calibrate them for use in specific
Vehicles a robot holds the sensor in
front of a laser which etches the DAT of
manufacturer back on a conveyor the
throttle position sensor travels under a
magnifying glass so that the laser
etching job can be
scrutinized this throttle position
sensor is now ready for detection
Duty